he does whatever a spider can but what
about body-swapping in an interview with
comics explained spider-man actor Tom
Holland revealed that he would love for
Peter Parker and Wolverine to team up
for a body swap movie comics explained
asked Holland which Marvel movie world
outside of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
he would like to appear in and Holland
had his answer at the ready citing a 15
year old ultimate spider-man storyline
and then when green wakes up in Peter
Parker's body and he like goes to school
southern Peter Parker's like being this
really gross rude man and he like starts
hitting on the school teacher in
Hollands spider-man far from home
co-stars end day up who plays Michelle
MJ Jones and a current spider-man film
series was keen on the idea what is that
what are you doing he's doing his
Wolverine thing yeah for those
unfamiliar with ultimate spider-man the
issues Holland is referring to our
ultimate spider-man number 66 and number
67 from 2004 the story was also loosely
adapted into an episode of Disney XD's
ultimate spider-man cartoon series in
2012 this mask smells you complete me
issue number 66 sees Peter Parker and
the powerful mutant Wolverine coming
together after a bizarre occurrence ties
them to each other the two heroes try to
decode the mystery and all the while
their personal lives begin to unravel
together number 66 and number 67 tell a
classic Freaky Friday tight body swap
tale horiz marvel's official description
of number 67 puts it Wolverine and
spider-man have always been in each
other's faces today they're in each
other's bodies
as holland explained ultimate spider-man
number 66 sees Peter waking up and not
recognizing anything in his house in his
hotel room Wolverine is experiencing the
same confusion he doesn't know who he is
and is startled by his appearance while
telling Mary Jane Watson that he really
doesn't want to go school Peter gets a
phone call from Wolverine their
conversation leads to the big revelation
they've swapped bodies Peter and
Wolverine meet at school where Wolverine
in Peters body is skipping class when
Peter and Wolverine are about to leave
Peter and Wolverines body heads toward a
car chase which leads to an unfortunate
event involving an enormous truck
ultimate spider-man number 67 picks up
right where number 66 left off and
follows Peter and Wolverine as they try
to figure out a way to reverse the body
swap after a string of hilarious mishaps
fellow x-men member Jean Grey saves the
day in a hilarious twist holland's chat
with comics explained caught the
attention of Brian Michael Bendis the
writer behind the Peter Parker and
Wolverine body swap story Bendis
retweeted a video clip of the interview
adding in the caption everyone else can
see this too right when it comes to a
potential body swap movie with
spider-man and Wolverine it isn't so
much a question of whether it can't
happen but rather a case of whether
Marvel Studios would want to do it now
that the Walt Disney Company owns the
majority of 20th Century Fox's assets
Wolverine and the rest of the x-men
squad are property of the mouse house
and more specifically Marvel Studios
though Marvel's head honcho Kevin Feige
has mentioned that it will be a handful
of years before the Disney Fox merger
would impact the MCU he is looking to
recast Wolverine with a younger actor
when the studio inevitably reboots the
x-men team it's only a matter of time
before fans witness a new Wolverine
entering the MCU where Holland
spider-man is already a major player
will the two cross paths and swap bodies
for a big-screen feature sometime in the
future
Never Say Never check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos about the MCU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]